tiempo de hablar de economía aquí en
france 24 ya estamos para eso con
nuestra periodista daniel hablando que
nos va a contar los temas principales de
esta jornada daniela empezamos en mexico
profe crisis de abastecimiento de gas
natural que está liliana buenas noches
mire las bajas temperaturas en el sur de
eeuu han limitado el flujo de
combustible desde texas esto a su vez ha
generado cortes de energía eléctrica
como el que el lunes afectó a unos 47
millones de usuarios hay empresas que
han tenido que parar su producción
inclusive como los fabricantes de
automóviles ford fiat toyota nissan y
general motors en medio de esta
situación apareció desde suramérica una
llamativa oferta para el gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador
viendo los planes de producción de gas
nosotros deberíamos proponernos
seguros suministradores de gas a méxico
para su eficiencia energética es una de
las metas nuevas que propongo la
comisión presidencial suministrar el gas
venezolano a mexico es una oferta
similar recibió colombia hace unos años
cuando venezuela se comprometió a
exportar le gas natural desde el primero
de enero de 2016 pero hasta la fecha no
ha pasado el primer pie cúbico por la
frontera ligada también ahí hablamos
ahora era así porque el gobierno eliminó
temporalmente el impuesto al diesel y al
gasto si hace un par de semanas
amenazaron con ir a huelga general los
camioneros de brasil los mismos que
apoyaron a jair bolsonaro en las
elecciones presidenciales todo por el
aumento en el precio de los combustibles
el presidente cedió ante estas presiones
y anunció una exención tarifaria por dos
meses del impuesto al diesel y al gas
para a partir del primero de marzo para
el caso del diesel dijo que además se
analizará la manera de suprimirlo
definitivamente y es que el mandatario
ha criticado a la estatal petrobras por
las falsas
para y se aplican tres impuestos
federales a los combustibles que
representan el 9 por ciento del precio
mientras que otro 14% lo cobran los
estados también para el gas domiciliario
habrá una exención del impuesto que
equivale a un 3% del valor de la pipeta
daniela y hablamos de españa que busca
recuperarse económicamente facilitando
la creación de nuevas empresas
liliana el ministerio de economía lanzó
este viernes a consulta un proyecto para
preguntarle a la comunidad en general
cómo puede mejorar el clima de negocios
y la inversión el gobierno dice que la
eliminación de barreras a la entrada de
empresas en el mercado es aún más
relevante en este contexto de impacto de
la economía por la crisis sanitaria esta
iniciativa de la que se recibirán
opiniones hasta el 19 de marzo tiene
tres propuestas concretas sobre la
creación de compañías primero que ya no
se necesite un capital de tres mil euros
sino de un euro segundo que el trámite
sea 100% digital y tercero que dure
apenas diez días y hablamos del vaticano
que dio a conocer su informe detallado
de finanzas pues no es muy usual que la
santa sede- presente sus cifras
discriminadas pero el papá francisco ha
advertido que quiere darles más
transparencia a estas cifras del
vaticano en medio de los más recientes
escándalos de corrupción para este año
se espera un déficit de 50 millones de
euros debido a la pandemia con ingresos
por 260 millones de euros y gastos por
310 millones pero aquí están contado ya
con el aporte de los fieles que sí
dejarán de dar lo llevaría en el déficit
a 80 millones de euros la pandemia hizo
que los ingresos del año pasado
efectivamente cayeran en un 21% no sólo
por el cierre de las iglesias sino
también de la basílica de san pedro y
los museos del vaticano que apenas
tuvieron 1,3 millones de visitantes el
año pasado cuando normalmente son más de
7 millones
daniela y cuéntenos cómo están para hoy
los indicadores de la jornada wall
street' del cerro mixto pero sin grandes
cambios una semana que marcó varios
récords en sus principales índices las
bolsas europeas subieron impulsadas por
mejores datos de actividad
industrial en la zona euro y en américa
latina las presiones de bolsonaro a
petrobras por el precio de los
combustibles lleva un cierre rojo en la
bolsa de sao paulo y finalizamos con la
cifra del diagnóstico son 8 mil millones
de euros en pérdidas que reportó el
grupo francés el reyno en 2020 este es
el peor resultado de su historia y 56
veces más de lo que perdió en 2019 pues
gracias daniela por la información de
colombia y ustedes gracias por estar en
tras 24 continúen con más entradas 24
punto com y por supuesto aquí con más
información
i